metro
lejos de él
ap
eres bueno esa es la carta pero si
este es mi presidente sabes que el
nos dio el aguijón
el domingo un terrorista suicida en roma otra vez i
Soy estudiante, así que soy mi
presidente francés
[Música]
como mucha gente hoy
relativamente decepcionado con este cartel porque
que esperaba un cambio voté
por el cambio y nos volvamos a encontrar
con los mismos protagonistas en la segunda
gire asi que aqui esta decepcionado
[Música]
es lo que tenemos la opción si
peste o cólera
entonces mi muerte pero rabin realmente es
lástima que la clase política lo
parada en casal hecho es la gente
que tienes que escuchar no es el
políticas
[Música]
[Aplausos]